everyone is weighing in on the state of
the union but only one opinion doesn't
matter that of my good friend judge een
pyro the state of the Honu Yin I was
watching because Dance Moms was a rerun
mr. president you're killing America
you're beheading America when you raise
taxes for hard-working billionaires so
that a freeloading pothead can go to
Community College the terrorists didn't
just win their victory dancing on the
American flag it's all part of the
immigrant Ebola Isis agenda I've been
talking about an agenda to starve the
biggest military in the world into the
biggest military in the world that's
less big first it's a health care system
Stalin had only dreamed of and now the
president wants to make us read what
part of they're coming for us doesn't he
get and Shakespeare won't protect you
the irony is mr. president that when
they get educated the freeloaders will
become wealthy while the wealthy will be
writhing and destitute with only a
two-car garage and once freeloaders are
rich according to your plan you'll just
make them poor again do you really want
to create more poor people just so poor
people can then become rich and then
poor again when there are so few jobs as
is because they've been traded to China
for chicken chow mein and eunuch glow
just ask my pool cleaner gardener
housekeeper landscaper wig attendant and
wig attendant assistant there just
aren't that many jobs to go around
anymore
maybe if toilet seat warmer food chewer
or second pillow fluffer but that's just
extravagant you can hand out the
American dream you've got to earn it
through hard work and pitting your race
against others Pakistanis at the top of
the list and that's my gaping opening
tell me what you think on Facebook so my
assistants in turn can ignore it
good night and
all going to die
you